a bit of breaking news that we can bring
you now from uh the supreme court it's
just handed down its judgment in a case
board against google for collecting web
browsing data from iphone users well our
correspondent iva bennett is at the
supreme court and can tell us more i
mean this was quite a big case either
yeah it was it was seen as a very big
case potentially um very legally
significant because of the potential
repercussions had the court ruled
against google but in fact they have
ruled in favor of google that's happened
in the last few moments with the ruling
read out by
lord leggett they have blocked a class
action
against google and essentially maintain
the status quo on class actions
representative actions whereby they can
only be brought with the opt-in the
express say-so of every uh potential
claimant i can read you the key line
from the ruling now the supreme court
unanimously allows the appeal that
refers to the appeal
google's appeal of a ruling from the
court of appeal earlier and restores the
order made by the judge and that refers
to the original ruling by the high court
which ruled in google's favor now the
significance of this case is not the
claim itself but more the way it was
brought the substance of the claim is
that google secretly illegally uh
tracked the internet activity of
millions of iphone users between 2011
and 2012 regardless of whether or not
they had chosen the do not track option
on their safari web browser
but the supreme court was not ruling on
that instead they were ruling on whether
or not the claimant a man called richard
lloyd could bring a case on behalf of
everyone who had been affected so that's
estimated to be
4.4 million people in england and wales
if the court had ruled in his favor it
would have been illegal first allowing a
class action
without the opt-in of everyone involved
normally class actions can only be
brought with the express permission of
uh every single claimant and requiring
some sort of proof of fact through uh
pertaining to those
individuals but as i say the the court
has ruled against him and in favor of
google it basically means the
google is off the hook for what could
have been a very hefty fine indeed they
could have potentially had to pay out up
to 750 pounds to everyone involved
millions of users which could have been
a bill looking at three billion pounds
but as i say they're off the hook and
the status quo on representative class
actions has been maintained
all right either thanks for that